el 15 de julio de este año el ejército
turco se levantó contra su propio
gobierno no es la primera vez que pasa
en realidad es la quinta en menos de 50
años a este paso los golpes de estado en
turquía van a convertirse en una
tradición local como lo es comer baklava
o visitar santa sofía
hoy vamos a explicaros de dónde viene
este golpe de estado y qué consecuencias
puede tener y lo vamos a hacer por dos
razones primero porque nos lo habéis
pedido y segundo porque es un tema muy
importante que apenas lo han cubierto
los medios de comunicación al menos en
españa- lo cierto es que es muy difícil
determinar quiénes son los buenos en
esta historia por un lado es cierto que
el ejército ha intentado atacar a un
gobierno elegido democráticamente pero
por el otro erdogán es a la democracia
lo mismo que la salchipapa es a la
canción pop melódica sin embargo este
intento de golpe de estado es
probablemente la noticia más importante
de este verano y por eso es muy
importante que entendamos todo el
trasfondo político que hay detrás si
queréis profundizar más en el golpe de
estado turco os recomendamos que veáis
el vídeo que ha hecho míster x en su
canal se trata de un canal amigo
dedicado a la geopolítica encontraréis
el link en la descripción de este mundo
y porque turquía es tan importante
turquía tiene 80 millones de habitantes
casi la población de alemania además su
ejército es el segundo más grande de la
otan sólo superado por el de eeuu por si
esto fuera poco turquía es uno de los
pocos países de mayoría musulmana que
tiene una constitución completamente
laica y esto lleva siendo así desde que
se creó el propio estado turco después
de la primera guerra mundial su primer
presidente y padre de la patria
mustafa kemal atatürk diseñó un estado a
imagen y semejanza de europa más es más
llegó a prohibir vestimentas típicamente
musulmanas como el fet y a promover toda
clase de programas que fomentaran la
vestimenta occidental por supuesto
eliminó cualquier vestigio de ley
islámica del corpus legal turco el
precio de todas estas reformas fue la
represión de cualquier minoría que no
encajará bien con el modelo de estado
que atatürk tenían la cabeza para eso se
sirvió de un ejército enorme con una
gran capacidad de influencia en las
decisiones políticas
eso explica todos estos golpes de estado
hecho durante todos estos años en
turquía se han creado dos bandos por un
lado están los llamados turcos blancos
que son urbanos laicos y normalmente
trabajan en la administración pública
por el otro estarían los turcos negros
que son rurales mucho más pobres y no
ven demasiado bien eso de la separación
iglesia-estado
con respecto a la economía turquía nunca
ha terminado de despegar en fin ya
sabéis que en visual política no somos
muy amigos de la intervención del estado
en la economía pero es que el caso turco
es un ejemplo del libro de lo que ocurre
cuando todos los sectores de la economía
están centralizados en el estado pero es
que turquía es el ejemplo del libro de
lo que ocurre cuando casi todos los
sectores de la economía están
centralizados en el estado el resultado
es corrupción tráfico de influencias y
una élite de privilegiados que tienen
contacto con la clase dirigente y viven
mucho mejor que los que no lo tienen
todo esto regado con la salsa picante de
la inflación esto es el resumen de lo
que ha sido turquía a lo largo del siglo
20 pero esperad un momento porque en el
año 2003 llega el hombre destinado a
rescatar a este país de sus cenizas
i
erdogán o erdogán como diríamos en turco
era uno de esos turcos negros que pasaba
más tiempo en la mezquita que axel rose
en alcohólicos anónimos de hecho cuando
era alcalde de estambul pasó 10 meses en
la cárcel por haber leído en público un
poema que supuestamente incitaba a la
intolerancia religiosa nada más salió de
prisión creó un nuevo partido político
al que llamó justicia y libertad que
supuestamente era laico en 2003 ganó las
elecciones y se convirtió en primer
ministro su primer objetivo fue acabar
con la inflación y esto no es ninguna
tontería porque mira cuando hablamos de
inflación normalmente parece que es esa
cosa que solamente importa a los grandes
empresarios pero es lo que más nos
afecta en nuestro día a día
imagina por un momento que vivieras en
ankara en enero del año 2001 y compráis
una barra de pan por el precio de dos
ligas turcas seis meses después esa
barra de pan costaría el doble y lo
mismo con el resto de cosas que queramos
comprar sin embargo a lo mejor hasta el
año que viene no nos van a subir el
sueldo menuda putada verdad pues eso era
el pan
de cada día nunca mejor dicho en turquía
erdogán le puso punto final a la
inflación y lo hizo gracias a
liberalizar muchos sectores de la
economía y privatizar muchas de las
empresas públicas
aproximadamente el 85% de las personas
que votaron al partido justicia y
progreso lo hicieron por la economía
durante estos años
turquía se convirtió en la china de
europa empresas como ikea o inditex
abrieron muchísimas fábricas
aprovechando los salarios baratos y su
economía estaba aún fire
estambul se puso de moda como destino
turístico y de hecho si prestas atención
veréis que entre 2005 y 2010 hay un
montón de películas comerciales que
están ambientadas en esta ciudad
este balón no me gusta
de hecho los que seguís visual político
desde hace tiempo recordaréis un vídeo
que hicimos hablando de las ciudades que
más han crecido en el top 53 eran
ciudades turcas pero sin duda el mejor
símbolo de este milagro económico sería
turkish airlines una aerolínea que hace
20 años era un poquito del montón y que
hoy en día es una de las más grandes del
mundo rodeándose con otras como
lufthansa o fly emirates
este boom turco llegó a tal punto que
hasta en la unión europea se planteaban
incluir turquía entre los estados
miembros
erdogán se convirtió en un modelo a
seguir para todos los países musulmanes
era el ejemplo viviente de cómo se puede
combinar islam con democracia y
crecimiento económico el writing su
llegada a la capital egipcia parece la
recepción de un héroe pero esperado un
momento porque en 2013 las cosas se
empezaron a torcer
y la otra cara ver dogan como hemos
visto erdogán se había convertido en un
sex-symbol del mundo árabe y eso le
molaba durante las primaveras árabes
turquía jugó un rol muy importante para
poner y quitar dictadores especialmente
en su vecina siria lo cierto es que
erdogán nunca ha hecho buenas migas con
al asad así que en cuanto tuvo la
oportunidad ayudó a cualquier fuerza que
atacara al dictador sirio y si eso
incluye el daes ankara rechazó tomar
partido en acciones militares directas
contra los militantes del estado
islámico el problema que tiene llevarse
bien con el daes es que nunca te
devuelven los favores así que erdogán
hizo la vista gorda en la frontera de
siria con turquía y los del estado
islámico aprovecharon para cruzar como
pedro por su casa y dedicarse a reclutar
militantes en tierra turca el resultado
más de 195 muertos en 11 atentados
terroristas y todo esto en sólo dos años
por si esto fuera poco en 2013
aparecieron varios casos de corrupción
que apuntaban directamente
erdogán y aquí es donde la antigua
rockstar del mundo musulmán nos mostró
su cara más autoritaria
bloquea temporalmente twitter y youtube
y amenaza con prohibir google ojo esta
noticia es de un año antes del intento
de golpe de estado pero no sólo eso es
que desde el año 2010
erdogán ha metido en la cárcel a más de
82 periodistas es más según el índice de
libertad de expresión realizado por
periodistas sin fronteras
turquía está por debajo de otros
paraísos de la censura como lo pueden
ser rusia etiopía o mexico pero eso no
es nada comparado con lo que hemos
descubierto la semana pasada erdogán
hizo un llamamiento a su población para
que resistieran al golpe de estado del
ejército turco hasta ahí normal el
problema es como lo hizo
los ciudadanos turcos recibieron un sms
que les pedía que salieran a la calle a
resistir el golpe de estado o un sms a
su móvil personal o sea que erdogán
tiene una base de datos con todos los
números de todos los ciudadanos turcos y
no tiene ningún reparo en utilizarla muy
poquitos dictadores han llegado a tener
semejante control sobre su población
esto deja al mismísimo vladimir putin a
la altura de un premio nobel de la paz
por eso es tan difícil considerar a
erdogán como un líder democrático aunque
haya ganado unas elecciones y todo esto
por no hablar de las medidas de
excepción que está tomando después del
golpe de estado que darían para otro
vídeo
pero vosotros qué pensáis quién es el
bueno en esta película el ejército que
se ha cargado a más de 200 ciudadanos en
menos de un fin de semana o este nuevo
gran hermano turco al que llamamos
erdogán la verdad es que yo no lo tengo
nada claro podéis dejarme vuestra
opinión en los comentarios que como
siempre deriva en un debate
superdivertido los que conocéis este
canal lo sabéis muy bien si os ha
gustado este vídeo darle a like y
suscribiros al canal si no lo habéis
hecho todavía en este mes que viene
estamos preparando un montón de temas
que os van a encantar así que de verdad
suscribiros porque va a merecer la pena
un abrazo y hasta pronto